uh what the [ __ ] is this working retail
me
you worked at Claire's for two weeks
work at Claire's for two weeks like for
a video or just no to make a living okay
oh you're like you did as a bit right
yeah I needed money no no no hold on
hold on how how much time have you spent
working retail
the majority of my uh live pre-internet
oh okay well pre-internet career because
that makes it sound like Stolen Valor
like you're like I'm famous but I worked
at Claire's for two weeks trust me guys
[Laughter]
whoever was at Baskin Robbins nice
President Obama okay thank you guys and
uh
then I worked as a hostess at a Cajun
restaurant and then I worked at Claire's
and then I was a licensed insurance
agent worked customer service hell yeah
dude call center call center let's go
awful yeah awful so were you were you
like calling random people and pitching
them or no I wasn't sales I was customer
service oh so it's inbounds it was
inbound and I also worked at it was a
insurance brokerage so it wasn't like
Progressive or whatever it was like they
would call us we were the agency and I'd
be like I'm gonna help you today and
they're like well [ __ ] hailed them a
corn broke all the glass and I need to
file a claim and then I would pull up
their policy and be like sir you
neglected all coverage that would like
actually pay out for something like this
you only have liability because and I
quote because we record all the yeah the
calls right yeah this is calls being
recorded for quality assurance purposes
they're saved there and I would read on
you know March 17th 2016 you said and I
quote [ __ ] you dumbasses I'm not paying
for that [ __ ] like on record heard you
decline the service and so you're
calling in [ __ ] to me I did that 10
hours a day uh five days a week for
about a year damn I have never in my
life experienced like a clinical
depression like that it was otherworldly
and so I got out of that right stop
beating around the bush who's the
hottest dude in the call center how does
he in the call center
voice out of anyone who called you well
we had a whole oh anyone that called me
like it was the agents the agents were
hot did ever did anyone ever call in and
you were like oh like a cut like a
customer yeah like British guys
and I have to file a climb yeah they saw
a mouse fighting biscuits and I'm like
okay
sorry that was me
something else is bad
awful
stupid joke
really dumb because it's about you
because yeah but if there was someone
else here yeah yeah all right
[Music]
anyway yeah it was the agents were
always like fresh out of college [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and they would sell and then I would
service the policies and so they would
call and be like yeah Brandy it's so
nice talk to you like hope you're doing
well [ __ ] power and then he'd be like
can you do that for me thanks and then
hang up and I'd be like
do anything and then I was like I'm
making 11 an hour for the college degree
so that's awesome would you would you
ever see these people in person
sometimes got it this company was just
[ __ ] awful though like I I hope it
burns
to the ground a little bit bro well you
have the platform to burn it now I could
yeah I could drone strike this place
yeah yeah just a button yeah name drop
it name drop it I'll I'll whisper it
that's actually on the second part of
the episode the bonus that's gonna be
behind a pay wall oh yeah yeah I like
that I like that Britney incites a riot
in real time
in the bonus episode be sure to
subscribe yeah
well so what's the plan for uh I don't
know tonight no
yeah I don't know yeah so
we hidden lines or what whoa we hidden
rails or like what's good
uh when you did piercings at Claire's
yeah did you pierce people [ __ ] no no no
what did you do oh you just like worked
the cashier yeah I worked during
Christmas break too so it was Christmas
like when you come over from college you
wouldn't know you come home from college
and you
are
kidding
sorry sorry it's all right we'll get
there eventually um yeah you're right
I've never come home from college to my
white family being like we're so proud
of you
why are you in college you're famous now
that's good that sounds just like my dad
actually Dad Dad bring him out what do
your parents think about
first well because here's the T here's
the story yeah give us all of it well
you popped off did your dad please
decide to be like Britney if you if
you're a lesbian just tell me now I
don't want to find out later I don't
want to find after some tick tock
my daughter's munching on it
okay if you're eating muff tell me now
eating mop yeah that's crazy I mean you
said you said munching on it you're
munching on it yeah
equal
that is same caliber
um so I got fired from my job because of
the kombucha video what yeah [ __ ]
really I got fired from the call center
[ __ ] no after that I
yeah you [ __ ]
um after that
yeah [ __ ] you should have made that
stupid video then I wouldn't got [ __ ]
canned [ __ ] y'all and GT Dave you got me
fired
um
anyway yeah I worked at a bank after
that because I quit the insurance job
quickly and then I worked at a quick
year yeah well because it was like you
know you have to wait to get the next
job I couldn't just so yeah I started
working at a bank and trust in
Investment Services made 12 an hour
Communications calm degree
and I had been working there for three
months and that's when I got fired nice
and what was their reason well she
brought me in and she was like
the [ __ ] you're doing you can't be
making videos yeah basically she was
like you need to decide if you want to
be a young professional or if you want
to be a meme and I was like what the
[ __ ] kind of decision is that I should
have been like you're just jealous [ __ ]
you're ugly
you're mad as hell you're ugly [ __ ]
you're mad yeah you're right I'm your
boss you're fired yeah you're mad
yeah stupid [ __ ] mad you're an l and
I'm a dub
me to my 60 year old boss named Cheryl
yeah yeah you're just mad because I'm a
[ __ ] hot girl yeah so was she trying
to like was she trying to give you the
advice would she like are you gonna be a
young professional no she was like
basically telling me to delete all my
channels because if I want to have my
name associated with that bank I can't
um be doing things online with an alias
which was Brittany Broski because my
government name is not Broski and so she
was like you need to either delete all
your channels to work here or you leave
and I was like what the [ __ ] no that's
crazy and Texas became a Marxist it is
actually that point forward capitalism
is a disease
um yeah me working at a bank highlighted
on arson immediate arson
um
Texas is an at-will employment state so
the first 90 days of employment um they
could fire you because you're ugly yeah
and you can't sue them so they didn't
fire her that's weird
yeah yeah no uh on the 89th day they
fired me yeah so they got all the work
out of me they could and then they let
me go and I called my dad is that real
that's real 89th day 89th day and I was
after they need a good reason so after
that you can pursue legal action to be
like I was wrongfully terminated
whatever so damn uh they fired me 89th
day and I called my dad and I said I'm
putting an application to Outback
Steakhouse I was crying I was so
embarrassed you know because I'm like
[ __ ] around online and I got fired
yeah so uh I was like I'm gonna be a
waitress like I promise I'll I'll make
it okay because my dad is so like you're
18 you're out like no help and I was
like sick so uh I start I got my first
brand deal with GT Dave wow and from
there it kind of took off so that's
sweet
it's slayed and so what is your what do
your parents think now are they like
it's very very proud their which was
shocking because I was like my dad is uh
retired U.S Air Force pilot wow and I
was like what does his husband think
about all this
sorry your dad's catching Strays here
[Laughter]
what is your mom's boyfriend think about
your dad yeah yeah oh they get along
just fine another all friends
um
no I he was so supportive from the very
beginning because he was like he saw
that it made me happy and he saw how
[ __ ] miserable I was at everything
else so it was awesome I started making
uh internet money from that first brand
deal they flew me out to LA and I was
like Wow Wow and then I saw all the
places that like that [ __ ] golden age
of when all y'all were doing Vine of
like everyone lived on that in that
building and on Vine yeah I hate that
but that everything becomes a relic it
is it's like oh my God that was Emma
Chamberlain's first thing I was like
this is so I have such a warped
understanding of Hollywood not from like
Marilyn Monroe but like that's where
Gabby Hannah did that thing
that's where Amanda Cerny uh yeah yeah
nice yeah yelled at Lele pons so awesome